quand ils adorent c'était cette saison
2021 ben un peu particulière donc on
essaie de faire au mieux voilà toute
façon c'est de faire le job tous les
jours et puis voilà on verra vous ça me
mène toute façon c'est de bien bosser
mais quel point qui doit améliorer tel
point un petit peu tout je pense que tu
penses à petit peu tout voilà bon moi je
le service le jeu vers l'avant
je veux surtout là dessus donc surtout
ça mais pour un poids renforcé notre
point fort j'aime bien toutes les
surfaces
j'ai beaucoup joué sur terre battue donc
je me sens bien être le petit à petit ce
parce que le dur ça va être ça va être
ça peut être bien avec ma taille tout ça
donc ça va pour se dorer faire je suis
pas mal et il ya beaucoup de thomas qui
s'est mué en ce moment puisque les
concurrents ces incidents sont arrivées
d'un futur messie que les différences
entre un joueur comme toi un joueur qui
évolue au la constance pense un peu plus
stable dans les femmes déjà dans le jeu
et donc du coup dans le résultat dans
les résultats sur l'année
bon là je pensais surtout ça un peu plus
stable dans le
emotionnellement peut-être soul par
endroits je pense que c'est ça qui fait
la diff une génération de joueurs assez
performant avec nottingham
c
si bientôt coin de la rue si je puis
dire
quel regard tu dresses sur la génération
qui fait partie le sort une nouvelle
génération
bah je pense que ça va bien jouer voilà
je pense qu'il ya quand même des joueurs
qui jouent donc pas prêts à baisser
comme des monstres gasquet tsonga
trouvera donc voilà enfin qu'on fait
tout le boulot qui on verra on verra
comment ça va avancer
on verra plutôt au niveau des objectifs
personnels pour un mythe en vue
d'intégrer le top 100 dans un pièce le
temps où a été un équilibre assez
concret moi je vais aller au bout de mon
potentiel ce que je peux faire donc dans
l'idée le top 100 la pression de petits
une petite
bref moi c'est le top semble d'ailleurs
dans un premier temps et puis après on
verra
aller au bout de ce que je peux faire
façon
de nous décrire le quotidien d'un joueur
de tennis professionnel
ouais c'est une journée un peu web
échauffement échauffement
ça prend cinq minutes voilà une heure
après un entraînement le matin un peu de
récup plus pareil l'après midi sauf
montrent que la fin occupe donc bains
froids enfin il tient bon tout ça et on
oublie tout - sortie à plusieurs c'est
sanguinis comment alors moi je sois
scène à la fédération sorte national
d'entraînement et donc je voulais encore
à plusieurs on est un petit groupe c
avec un autre joueur et mon entraîneur
aussi bon on est bien cadré la chance
c'est quoi le programme pour l'instant
mais ces gens qui vendent à partir sur
quels tournois là c'est un peu compliqué
d'avoir des plans fin de va voir ça va
être ça va dépendre des listes mais du
coup lie à poitiers semaine prochaine a
priori ce sera entraînement peut-être en
suisse il ya un tournoi sur dur puis
après je penserai la terre battue ça va
arriver assez vite et culture il ya une
vidéo qui nous étaient en challenger on
n'ose pas le pub le plus tôt possible un
peu plus tôt possible le plus tôt
possible dès qu'on peut sentir le défi
sur ce très grand plaisir parce que bon
c'est tout le mal qu'on souhaite
merci